en réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est que
c'est l'aboutissement d'un long procès
c'est à dire que l'absence de bruno le
maire dans la discussion générale du
budget fait suite à son absence quasi
permanente aux questions d'actualité
fait suite à l'absence totale d'olivier
ferrand sur sur le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pendant
l'examen du texte et fait suite en fait
à une absence quasi permanente de tous
les ministres j'allais dire star de ce
moulin ce que ça veut dire messieurs
d'hermann à est rarement ces dames en
particulier oui ben je sais pas c'est ce
que c'est la question qui a été posée
par les différents présidents et
présidentes de groupe hier
voilà on voudrait parler au ministre
alors messieurs castex est là mais c'est
la moindre des choses était obligé mais
l'ensemble de ses ministres j'allais
dire vraiment fort condé condé des
compétences extrêmement lourdes ne sont
jamais là et monsieur bruno le maire
empêché enfin il était quand même sur
les plateaux de télévision dans l'après
midi
je trouve que l'on doit être devant le
parlement plutôt que devant les plateaux
de télévision d'ailleurs je devrais
voilà je devrais y être mais vous étiez
dans l'émission j'étais dans l'édition
d'hier soir et j'ai été ce matin et j'y
serai demain mais mais voilà je crois
qu'on a besoin aussi d'être respectés
d'être entendu et je crois que le grand
malaise démocratique dans lequel on se
trouve aujourd'hui il vient aussi de ça
il vient du manque de considération de
ce gouvernement pour le parlement d'une
façon générale et je parle pour le sénat
mais je parle aussi pour l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]